who are you well angel
what do you want from me change
what you're doing now is such a low blow
demolishing the lives of all the people
you know so dolly your first holiday
album
that you've come out with in 30 years
congratulation
i was just listening to it there's a
song on the album called christmas on
the square so we wanted to know which
came first the movie or the song well
actually the movie sam haskell
uh my partner and he also executive
produced the christmas on the square
movie
for netflix well he was uh going to
write a book
some years back a couple three years ago
he was writing a book and he was going
to call it christmas on the square and
he had this basic idea
and i said no why don't we do that as a
as a movie
and let's do it as a musical and i'll
write all the music for it
so that's how it all started now when i
put it in my
uh in my new album the holly doll holly
christmas
uh my new cd i did a a more country
bluegrass version of it of course in the
movie it's more of the broadway bigger
musical but i wanted to kind of tone it
down and make it more like a little
country
country or town so uh i did want to put
it in the movie i used two songs
christmas is from the netflix movie
christmas on the square
uh in my album i did christmas eve with
miley cyrus
as a duet in my album and uh so
and then christmas on the square you
know i just wanted to have two so i
could talk about them
too when i promoted the album i could
talk about the movie we're talking about
the movie i could talk about the album
you know me
always thinking but anyhow uh so to
answer your original question
the christmas on the square movie came
first okay i love it yeah that song
christmas is
is my favorite next to the one you sing
with jimmy fallon which is just
so funny but you wrote 14 original songs
for this film so is it challenge
do you find it more challenging to write
songs for movie musicals
well it is i had a wonderful partner in
maria slaughter who wrote the script for
this and she's very creative and
we worked really close together so she
made it more fun and she really knows
that world so she'd give me thoughts
well here's
kind of what this should be about and i
think this you know so we made a good
team with that
but i i just loved being able to do it
because i love a challenge i love
somebody saying
do this do that it brings me up a little
bit i think and
rather than just being left to my own i
want to please people
and i want to impress people so i worked
really hard
trying to to write it but it was very
fun to do
i i was inspired with all the songs yeah
well i feel like you're inspired just
watching it and you definitely rose to
the challenge i mean you're
you killed it's so inspiring how dolly
how do you write a christmas song like
what is the recipe
on putting a christmas song together
well
you know it's funny every writer wants
to be able to write christmas songs
that might become classic someday but
you know you think well everybody's
written everything about everything
about christmas
but then you just for me for this i kind
of based it on the story
and the characters and what who i
thought they were so
i just for this particular one i just
kind of based it on
what they needed to say and i knew what
it was supposed to be about and that it
was christmas so
you just kind of sit and kind of let the
light shine down and
grab what you can and just go after it
yes
well thank you so much and then
christine this isn't your first
christmas rodeo you know you were in
how the grinch stole christmas of bad
moms christmas so what was it like
coming back to do this christmas film
well i had just been in atlanta the year
before doing bad moms christmas in which
i also played a very mean mom
so okay atlanta again mean again
but christmas again but there's dolly
parton
so um yeah any any chance
you get to sing the music of a great
songwriter is
is a gift especially since i'm not
i i don't primarily sing i i'm mainly an
actress so that the chance that i could
play a great role a complicated role
like regina
plus seeing dolly parton plus meet dolly
parton
plus get to be your girlfriend for a
little while that was all i mean there
are no
there are no downsides here this was all
this was all great
and as we've said before none of us knew
that we would be making a movie that
would be so such a gift to the world at
this moment in time
you know that you know a time when
people
are having to think more about community
and wanting
wanting to feel happy in a deeper way
you know we're all very tired of being
angry and feeling dark and
you know separated from each other so
this movie's a real gift
it truly was it like lifted my spirits
and even dolly you coming out you know
with your album
earlier this like in september i was
like i'm so happy i just want to listen
to christmas music we all need like that
uplifting content and you guys delivered
so thank you but
christine you're also i know you know
you were saying you're mainly an actress
but you're no stranger to musicals
um so what was it like getting to mesh
christmas and musicals together
i i think christmas lends itself to me
music because of christmas carols and
people as i said in another interview
people even with bad voices will just
chime in and sing
i remember my family members all in the
living room singing christmas carols and
and listening to my family singing
polish
music and christmas music going to
church and hearing beautiful christmas
carols
it's a musical time it's a lyrical time
it's a time of the heart and because
christmas
is about heart and the birth of christ
and and light
that's where music comes from i always
say to my little grandson i
say where does music come from and i do
this
and i make him do the gesture where does
music come from
comes from the heart oh that's so sweet
i love that
um they're wrapping me up so i have one
last question
dolly i was hoping you could just tell
us what your heartwarming christmas
christmas message is to everybody
watching right now
well i just want everybody to know that
there is love and love is everything
christmas
is about caring it's about sharing it's
about giving it's about
doing for someone else and i really
believe that
we're just going to all be pulled
together this year and really
have to be forced to really know what
the true meaning of christmas
is but i think it's a joyful time and i
think we need to find
all the joy in it that we can even
though things are sad and
kind of scary around us it's going to be
all right there's a light
up there and a light in here so let it
shine
oh that was so beautiful well christine
and dolly thank you both so much i
absolutely love this thing i can't wait
to watch it with my parents when i'm
reunited with them again and i hope you
both have a wonderful holiday and thanks
for sitting down and talking to us
thank you merry christmas hi merry
christmas
christmas is time for caring being at
your best
christmas is a time for sharing knowing
you've been blessed
christmas is a time for angels making
things all right
hello hello merry christmas you guys
look fabulous
i know that the both of you are actually
friends so i first wanted to know what
was it like working on this together
oh it was a dream come true i love
jennifer lewis
i've loved her since the moment i've set
eyes on her
she had a talent bigger than life
she honed herself here in hollywood
and we worked together one time and then
i couldn't get her because she got to be
so
popular she was in movie after movie and
so i was thrilled
that i had her phone number in my cell
phone to call her to tell her come on
honey i need you
no debbie allen call i was
in antarctica
she says you've got to come do my movie
i said i'm on a ship and ice
but when debbie allen calls i answer
and as soon as i got off the plane i
went directly to the debbie allen dan
studio
and she began right away she took me
right back to broadway
i hadn't danced in years i hadn't really
sang in a long time
and she brought everything out of us
dolly christine treat she brought those
characters to life she brought those
dances to life and i just say to
everyone
see christmas on the square and get your
joy for the holiday yes yes yes
exactly what it was it just it's so
uplifting so what an amazing thing to
work on you know this year and to give
to everyone this year especially but
jennifer i got to go back to antarctica
in a little bit
you just dropped antarctica and that's
amazing
um debbie this next question is for you
though you know you
you directed this you choreographed this
how did grey's anatomy prepare you
you know to direct this film it wasn't
grey's anatomy i did this on fame
fame was like going to film school
graduate film school for
six years and that's where i honed my
skill as a director i was the
choreographer
i became their favorite director i
became the producer
i became everything on that show and it
was an incredible opportunity for me
to define my skill as the director and
so every time i direct like when i did
scandal
grace how to get whatever i did they
would carry washington said to me one
day when i staged the scene for her
there were eight people and said you're
gonna go here you're gonna hear me
she said this is choreography i said yes
darling every
it's called motion pictures moving so
grey's anatomy is some
is an incredible opportunity that i have
every day
to participate in a show that changes
people's lives
that tells a truth and so grey's anatomy
informed me
specifically about a scene where we
i don't want to give it away but there
is an accident and there's a hospital
so i knew everything about it because
linda klein had taught me everything i
need to know about what happens in a
procedure
and but it was really the joy of the
story
that captured me and the music and the
ability to work with this incredible
cast jennifer lewis
christina baranski matthew johnson who
nobody the world will discover him in
this film
discover him and my little girl selah
and
janine i mean oh my god just it was a
joy and dolly just we can't even say
enough about her
you know we can say we can say that she
wore
a lot of rhinestones in the movie
i mean let's say dolly pardon brings the
music
hey and she brings the rhinestone
and to cap that off
dolly parton wears
high heels this high and one day i said
to her she was standing on a box i said
dolly
you can take those off now if they're
painful
she turned to me and said
jennifer i gotta wear my shoes
oh my god her name
dolly parton's name should have been
sugar sugar ice cream
cotton candy christmas morning and sugar
so warm it's her warmth it's her warmth
i had other questions that i have to ask
you guys now like there has to be one
story from set that you guys can share
when you think back to like
filming you know putting making
christmas on the square
what pops out to you like what memory do
you guys have all together with dolly
the memory i have was i my butt was
pressed to the line i had to shoot this
movie in a certain time
i knew how to do it good at that i'm
trying to set up a shot
the cast is missing jennifer has taken
them into the bar
where there's a real piano and they are
sitting around there singing songs
and have i'm like what the hell y'all
need to get
back on the set and jennifer was talking
back i snatched her wig off
it was all in fun but it was in the
moment because
she's such a she's such a honey to the
bees
they just gather around her she said we
gotta sing this song
i didn't have time for that i needed to
get this shot done
well working with debbie i like i have
told many people this morning she gave
me my start in hollywood
um so when she calls
i answer you know and
wow we just had a good time come on
christine baranski
jennifer lewis treat williams debbie
allen
and then that big party you gave
yes that was so i'm when i tell you i
was behind
dolly laughing at something so hard
she's like jennifer
are you all right said yes
i mean falling and carrying on with all
these women
with all of this female energy
happening the hope that
the movie brings the joy
the forgiveness and the music the
dancing and the music
what's not to like i agree what i want
to end on
what is your heartwarming christmas
message to both of you to everyone
watching right now
jennifer we'll start with you i say this
and i mean it
stay safe we are used to
gathering we're used to traveling over
the holidays
we all have to grow up and evolve
to a new behavior so please stay safe
this holiday season
and be smart protect the people you love
i would say christmas is a form for
giving
and for giving yes
giving to someone and to forgive
and that is i would say to the world
right now
what what can you give and who can you
forgive
and keep the music going keep
the music going
you guys just made my year i love you
thank you so much for talking to rotten
tomatoes and i can't wait for the world
to see christmas on the square so you
guys have a fabulous rest of your day
thank you
and they shine so brightly hello you
look so
pretty how are you thank you so do you
it's
dolly you know like with today's the day
for glam in 2020.
that's so true well you killing look
amazing so
in this film not only are you acting
opposite of dolly parton but you are
singing and dancing opposite of dolly
parton so i have to know
were you nervous what was it like
working with her
i i couldn't believe it i just couldn't
believe it
i i honestly just thought okay every day
up until now you've been training for
this you know it sort of felt like
the olympics for me and it was my
first time ever singing on camera this
is my first movie musical
um so when that when word of this duet
first came to me i just couldn't
actually believe it and
she was so gracious with me and kind and
um
uh i just don't even know how i made it
through but i do
just i remember doing the last bit of
the song where we're singing into each
other's faces
and we're i'm harmonizing with her
just being like this is real life and
just being so
overwhelmed by how lovely and easy it is
for her like she just makes you feel
comfy
so god bless her because it got me
through but i do
it was one of those moments where you're
like commit this to memory this
is actually unbelievable you know i
would be reflect like i
i don't know what to do that's that's it
were you um were you a fan of dolly
growing up
such a fan absolutely obsessed with her
i mean as an icon
um as a woman i mean her
shape her brazenness her work ethic her
music
all of it i mean she's truly an icon
it's like her and rbg you know what i
mean
um for us nominees ladies so i just
couldn't
i i couldn't believe this and then i
also found out while shooting
that my mom came up to atlanta and
visited and i'm cuban american i'm from
miami florida my mom
told me that my grandfather who passed
away when i was in high school was a
huge dolly fan and i never knew that
about him and
you know when they immigrated to the
states it was really it was like
dolly you know her star was on the
ascent and and
and she was everything great and good
and beautiful and
and and opportunity in this country she
exemplified that
um and so this just felt like such a
full circle moment and i
i have to believe he had a hand in it
and he's enjoying all of this so much
it's so funny you say that because i'm
also from miami i'm dominican and my
parents
are obsessed with her so i think they
probably came here around the same time
which is just hilarious
oh my god i love it did you do any like
fun stories from set with dolly or like
any moments where you're shooting with
her that you're like i'm never gonna
forget this
oh man so many that
that and some that i just like and like
keeping as like little secrets for
myself that just like
keep my heart warm but she gave me guy
advice one day and i just
that was another moment where i was just
like this is unbelievable
like i'm just saying i couldn't believe
it she it was
it was more like she has um she was like
trying to get me to understand that like
i should have all the confidence in the
world
when it comes to men and i was like i
mean
thank you like i just couldn't believe
it
um and then she just and then honestly
the the rest was just watching her work
was just
she does not stop and i mean she truly
she will go back to her bus in between
setups and she's working on
this is not a joke 10 other projects and
and
all all coming from an engine of really
just wanting to do right by the world
and take care of people so it's just
amazing to watch that and i just was
like okay
let me just move forward with this with
like if if this
is if this is what is moving her
engine like it is the secret that all of
us should be embracing so
um unbelievable watching her work i love
that message right like the intention is
really the most important thing
you really like feel it through all of
dolly's songs and all her work i mean
this last album is your 47th solo studio
album it's insane
um what was it like working with debbie
allen because you're in grey's anatomy
so
you're working with debbie on grey's
anatomy what was it like working with
her on a christmas musical movie
unbelievable this is this is i've been i
just keep saying unbelievable
i'm sorry but that's where i'm at with
this um
she this was my third time working with
debbie allen my first job straight out
of miami
was so you thinking dance and debbie was
a judge on that
and then i got to work with her on
grey's anatomy as an actor and as a
director and she's the mama bear of that
set so that was just
a whole nother level in in our working
relationship and
and in my admiration of her and our
friendship and then
you know when this all came together she
had assumed i was working on
on my show roswell new mexico and so
when this worked out she was like girl i
didn't know you were available i would
have called you earlier and i was like
debbie i'm always available for you i
need you to understand that
like please call call like i'm just
obsessed with her
any opportunity i'll take it that's so
cool
i can't believe this was your first time
singing on screen you were
absolutely incredible what um what
heartwarming christmas message do you
have for everyone
um watching this right now i mean it's
really what what
what i took away from dolly which is it
ultimately at the end of the day
what we do and our contributions to the
world
what makes them powerful is their
ability to
communicate to another person that
they're not alone you know and
dolly is so about that she she truly
left me with that those are my last day
on set with her she said to me you know
if we could
just lift each other out of our sadness
and we could lift somebody out of their
sadness for the hour or two
of our entertainment that is our job
that's what it's all about and
um i mean who would have known that this
year
would line up with this i i have
always wanted to do a christmas movie
because i just think it's just such so
fun and i can't wait to be in miami like
watching with the family on the couch
you know
but for it to be with all these magic
people and her in particular
and for her message to be so purely her
purely dolly and so needed this year
the timing it just really just it feels
like such a
a cosmic lineup like a gift a gift gift
so
um i'm so grateful and i hope everybody
loves it it's so just
nostalgic yumminess and i just i just
want everyone to just be wrapped up in
it you know
yeah i do and thank you so much for
making it and being in it because i feel
like it really is just what the world
needs so
thank you so much for sitting down and
talking to us and i hope you have a very
merry christmas
oh thank you babe you too all right
you